[Music]
hello YouTube just love us in my friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 42nd episode of dirty
chess tricks since the chess evolution
if there is one opening which
consistently played from beginner to
master level then it has to be Italian
game due to the Berlin wall
nowadays many good players are switching
from roller pays to Italian game and it
has been frequently appearing in
tournament practice from both the colors
now during this episode I'm going to
demonstrate a tricky line in the modern
Italian game against one of the most
popular setup by black the opening
arises after the following model
efore 'if i Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 and now the Italian game
appears with Bishop to c5 ok the line
continues with C 3 so if allowed then
white will definitely play the move d4
so accordingly black do the
counter-attack with Knight to f6 and
white can play d4 and enter into the
Greco's attack but the modern Italian
game continues with d3 where white aim
for the slope positional plane
now as I've edited oh here black has
tried numerous moves but the move which
we are going to concentrate in this
video is defy this is one of the most
popular choice by black and in fact in
online database there are more than 700
games played from this position so as a
wide you should know exactly why D far
is a turn out as a big time disaster he
why should obviously capture this pawn
and after night captures defy here comes
the move which is a completed refutation
of this line and that is Queen to b3 so
we are attacking the defy Knight and as
you can see black has plenty of choices
but neither of them give any surviving
chances let's see each byte on the first
move I want to consider is the sea
Knight move so let's say if Knight goes
to the FI which looks very natural
attacking to sports but after Queen to
b5 black is going to lose his dark
square Bishop and in fact there is
hardly any compensation for it well same
goes if the sea Knight go to the e7
which also looks great because it's
supporting the knight but this leads to
the same problem yup you guessed it it's
very easy Queen to b4 checked and the
dark square bishop disappeared from the
ball very quickly
okay then well how about if black try to
support the knight with the vision let's
say Bishop to e6 this is again a big
time stick by black and the easiest
refutation is here you can take this
loose pawn on b7 with the Queen once
again the c6 Knight hangs and it cannot
move because then white can deliver the
check and nab the dark square Bishop so
accordingly black has the only reply in
this position and that is Knight d2 e7
supporting the c6 Knight but
unfortunately this allows the following
transition Bishop captures ecigs pawn
captures ecigs and now simple castle on
the King side and not only black has a
horrible horrible pawn structure all
around the board but white emerged with
an extra pawn in five
I have reached this position in a blitz
game against a 2000 rated opponent and I
just like to illustrate how easy this
position is to play as a white hear my
opponent continue it rook to b8
attacking the Queen
I played Queen to a6 defending my extra
pawn on d3 my opponent keep harassing my
queen with rook to b6 and I calmly play
Queen to see for attacking the bishop
attacking the e6 pawn so black responds
his force black has to play Queen to
defy saving both the threat but now why
take the in charge up the game and start
creating the threats Knight to g5
attacking on e6 black played Knight to
d8 defending another attacking move
before hitting the bishop bishop dropped
back to d6
Bishop to e3 attacking the rook and I
think my opponent was already fed up
with his position and he continued with
rook to b8 which turned out as another
big mistake as after the simple move
Bishop captures a seven white obtained
to pawn advantage and those are distant
passer which are not easy to stop after
few moves white easily convert the full
point okay then let's see what happened
if black tried to move the denied the
first move I want to consider is Knight
to b6 well it is very obvious that when
the D Knight moves the f7 pawn hangs and
we are more than happy to take it as
black king will be completely misplaced
he cannot come to e7 because of the
simple Bishop to g5 check and black
loses the Queen so the only safe spot
for the black king is to play King to a
fade but after this
what has the another lethal reply Bishop
to h5 so threatening Queen to have seven
checkmate
if black defend either
let's say Queen to e7 then white can
play the moon h3 and in this vision not
only white save his bishop and able to
misplace the black King but white also
emerge with an extra pawn so probably
the most critical response here is g6
which at first sight looks so scary as a
trap over light square bishop but in
fact technically this is justified
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a continuation
where actually you can safeguard your
light square bishop well let's see did
you find it
the radiation start with Bishop 2 at
6:00 check King to e8 Knight to g5
threatening Queen f7 checkmate and any
black moves with save the maid let's say
Queen to f6 now I can calmly retrieve
the bishop back to f3 and in all this
lines not only black King has been
misplaced but white emerged with an
extra pawn here I think the best choice
for the black is to play Knight to f6
allowing Bishop captures epsilon and
after King to f8 at least black has
stopped the move Bishop to h4 now if you
run this petition in the engine then he
will suggest that Queen to d1 is a best
reply and in fact there's a game in the
database between to 2600 plus rated
opponent where white gate of winning
position and in fact convert the full
point so I have attached that game in
the PGN so you might want to check out
if you are interested in Queen to diva
magician however my recommendation here
is to play this simple move Bishop to c4
giving back the pawn but in return get a
very comfortable position well the
accurate response from the black goes
like this Knight to e5 attacking 2p
kindly note queen-to-be fire doesn't
walk here because of the simple move b6
so instead of that why it should play
the move Queen to c2 which is in fact
the better move and after this the
sequence goes as follows night capture
sifu pawn captures c4 e for Knight to d4
Bishop captures d4 pawn captures d4 and
now by force black is getting his pawn
back with Queen captures before but
after the move castle it's okay that
black get his material back but the few
things if you carefully check it out
that black king is misplaced there's a
weak isolated pawn on the e4 square and
as I've highlighted over here very
simple and effective plan of campaign
from the white which gives him a very
active game if you still don't like this
then check it out the Queen to Devin
line finally at this position the
highest Lee played movies castle on the
King side which at first sight looks so
rubbish because white can simply grab a
piece right yes indeed but blacks idea
is after Knight to e5 he get his piece
back and also create a nasty trap first
of all let me show you what white needs
to avoid as this is happening few games
white played the obvious move Queen to
be Phi which attacking to sports but in
fact it is just an illusion as black and
simply recaptured the piece and White
Queen cannot even touch this night
because of yep bishop f2 and your queen
is a goner so kindly don't fall for this
also the another attractive movies
bishop to f7 and Vince upon but in fact
in this position if I tell you that
white can maintain his extra piece and
then you will be amazed right
it is true and before I proceed I like
you to pause this video and find out a
continuation wear white emerged with an
extra piece okay the continuation start
with the star mu Queen to d1
well black doesn't have any good choice
he has to take this bishop
otherwise he will be the piece down so
Queen kamsa's defy what else and now
comes before attacking two-piece and
after this the best continuation goes as
follows
efore counter attacking the knight white
was more than happy to take this pawn
and after Queen captures a foal of
course you don't want to play King to
have fun due to the Bishop to g4 and
black has some compensation but instead
of that the strong move Queen to e2 and
it doesn't matter however black plays he
is going to lose a piece if Queen
exchange then obviously this is benefit
to the white the other move rook to e8
doesn't threaten anything as after Queen
captures rook captures King to have fun
it is clear that black is going to lose
a piece and the best thing black can do
over here is Bishop captures before pawn
captures before rook captures before and
after the whole transaction white emerge
with a piece for a to pawn and any
professional chess player knows very
well that practically with some good
play this is a winning position for the
white that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and on this tricky line in the modern
Italian game after Queen to b3 it
doesn't matter however black responds if
you know these variations very well then
definitely you have a chance to obtain a
full point in the tournament thank you
for watching this feel free to write
subscribe and comment on this video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care